this has not been a good year for the
people of lake charles
this louisiana town has been flattened
not once but
twice by two severe hurricanes they're
still
struggling to clear up the mess weeks
later and the hurricane season
isn't over yet in the midst of all of
this the town
was engulfed by covet 19 infecting
people
and destroying the economy
joan arby's partner bridget caught the
disease
and then the hurricane destroyed their
house they're living in a motor home
this is my kitchen absolutely got a
dishwashing station
cooking station the pandemic meant that
joan
was put on part-time hours but after the
hurricane
she was made redundant all in all a
really bad year
what makes joan really interesting
though is that she's an undecided voter
it's very rare in the united states
these days
and in truth she's not really keen on
either of the candidates
i'm kind of on the fence in terms of
being conservative and liberal
but i think some of the things that are
being said
on the liberal side
are more um disturbing to me
than on the
conservative side so that's kind of
where i'm making
you know having to make a decision
as to who i'm going to vote for and
it's a very difficult decision and
like i said it's kind of a scary one as
well
undecided we joined joan as she went to
cast her vote this
is the last day of early voting in lake
charles
across the country people are setting
new records for voter turnout
whatever the polls show it's people like
joan who could
settle this election one way or the
other
what is the the sort of defining issue
of this
election freedom freedom
and what
will happen in the future for my
children
that's the defining issue for me
after an hour or so in line she finally
cast her vote
making up her mind at the voting booth
all done i feel a lot better now that
i'm
done now i've casted my vote
and let my and and know that i've i've
been heard
my one vote may not make a huge
difference but it does make some
difference are you going to tell us who
you went for in here
no i'm not telling you who i voted for
it may ruin some friendships
so i can't tell you that fear of
upsetting friends and relatives
is reflected across the united states a
country
that has arguably never been so divided
the question is will the final result
unite them
or make things even worse
mr ramsey sky news lake charles